[موسيقى]
اوكرانيا تسعى لان تتحول الى مركز عسكري
كبير لتوطين انتاج السلاح من خلال شراكه
مع مصنعي اسلحه غربيين ولهذا الغرض جمعت
كيف نحو 250 من شركات التصنيع الدفاعي
العالميه من 30 دوله في مكان
واحد ننشئ حاليا اول اسطول في العالم من
مسيرات بحريه ما يجعل السفن الروسيه بلا
فائده ويجبرها على الاختبار
بدانا في انتاج المدافع والذخيره من عيار
155 لقد توصلنا الى اتفاق مع الولايات
المتحده لانتاج مشترك فيما بيننا الرئيس
الاوكراني فلاديمير زيلنسكي وصف طرح بلاده
بانه شراكه متبادله المنفعه بين كيف
وداعميها فاكرانا تعتمد على الدعم المالي
والعسكري الغربي وحصلت على اسلحه وعتاد
تقدر قيمته بنحو 80 مليار دولار لكن طول
امد الحرب افرز نموا مضطر في الطلب على
اسلحه وذخيره قد هذا ان الدعم الغربي لكيف
قد يشهد
تحولا فبدلا من ارسال اسلحه وذخائر من
الحلفاء سيكون انتاجها في
اوكرانيا هذه المعطيات قد تؤشر الى ان
الحرب قد تطول لذا فا اوكرانيا بحاجه
لاعطاء دفعه للاقتصاد المحلي كما سيمكنها
توطين التصنيع من الحصول على ما تحتاج
اليه وتشير المعلومات الوارده من كيف انها
وقعت بالفعل مجموعه من الاتفاقيات مع
شركاء غربيين للانتاج المشترك وتبادل
التكنولوجيا وتوريد مكونات التصنيع بينما
كشف عدد من كبار المنتجين الغربيين من
المانيا وبريطانيا تحديدا عن خطط للتعاون
مع المنتجين الاوكرانيين فيما بقي قيت
اسماء شركات اخرى طي الكتمان ولتحقيق
مفهوم توطين الانتاج من المرجح ان تتولى
دول الغربيه تمويل راس المال الاوكراني
وتسهيل حصول كيف على رخص استخدام نماذج
الاسلحه وتمتلك كيف بالفعل تصنيعا عسكريا
محدودا قبل بضعه اسابيع اعلنت انها طورت
واجرت تجربه ناجحه لصاروخ اصاب هدفه على
بعد سب
ك اوكرانيا تعتبر وريثا لنحو 30 في من
مؤسسات الانتاج العسكري السوفيتيه ومن هذا
الارث الكبير شركات استراتيجيه مثل
انتونوف ومصنع مالي شيفا ومصنع موتور سيتش
وكانت اوكرانيا تحتل المركز الرابع عالميا
في تصدير الاسلحه والعتاد العسكري قبل
استيلاء روسيا على اقليم دونباس
وتتركز الصناعات العسكريه حاليا في
زبروجيا تحديدا حيث مصنع لانتاج محركات
مسيرات بيرقدار التركيه بينما تنتج
المسيرات الاوكرانيه في
ميكولايف